what would you say to anybody that's  trying to grow their clothing brand  auditing how much dollars they have to  put against it so if there's a couple  bucks then you can start really running  tick tock ads running amazon ads getting  a proper shopify infrastructure for a  clothing brand is a necessity for  organic tick tocks a day dm'ing  500 [ __ ] influencer celebrities a day  the problem is everything that you do in  the beginning is so hard  most people don't want to do it  everything i just said takes very very  little money absolutely but it takes 12  hours a day and people want to dm for 12  minutes and think they did something  they think they're gonna have a miracle  and they're gonna give gun a hoodie and  he's gonna wear it on stage and it's  gonna change their life that's just not  how it works content  content content putting out [ __ ] work  12 hours a day not one lucky moment